I defy anybody to tell me what women will do
next by this very moment they're shooting off
rocks pleading lawsuit putting out no directive
in exploring jungle when women were didn't stir
without their smelling salts and couldn't even
find the wave form without the strong male arms
alina when mother was it there that's the way
it was banned wasn't it well wasn't it no it
wasn't even then women were busily making they
had lie demanding the vote working for equal
rights pushing the boundaries of the world
apart for example what particular group of
with a band of khaki clad ideas who voted young
girls to get more out of life than T's and the
ladyfingers basically if the young girls should
be allowed to expand their horizons and do real
thing daring trying a newfangled airplane
and living in the outer door believe that
young girls should learn to be real who could
and clean and so didn't get the vapors from
the cat's eyes they hadn't named these pioneers
in khakis they call them selves in stock their
founder was a remarkable woman Juliet low who
had worked with Lord baby power in England and
made up her mind bring scouting home to American
girl so she came back in 1912 and started the
first Girl Scout troop and by 1918 she had well
let me show you something an impressive to the
pioneering in its own right you're going to see
one of the face public service movies ever made
she owned when Hollywood was still turning
out in the collodion thriller and designed
to show the world that's what Girl Scouting
was all about its producer mrs. wrong Thursday
and since we're going back into the past can
we conjure up a bit of the music of the period
yeah
Central Valley was the site of one of the first
Girl Scouts care of course there wasn't much
in the way of hometown attractions in those
days this is before television remember and
if you went to the movies you had to wait until
next week to CL Pro my God all for Korea that's
Margaret on the leg is that so of course
we never hear that from teenagers nowadays
they look like they've got something to do
and all traigo to join the parade amazing
that's julienne to lower
herself there on the right
here the soda polish stroller is learning the
mod but they all get the hang of it the right
words are in that Girl Scout Handbook if she can
just find them back there they are well maybe we
better try again left foot first mark all is
peace and quiet in Central Valley New York
yes it's our one Margaret now
neatly ponytail and here come
the other campers bright-eyed
and eager to start the new day
most appreciated
remember this was when the rest of the female
world was wearing long skirts and dusters and
well anyway doing calisthenics was very
emancipated so was the hearty appetite
there's Margaret outside air
in the blank I saw a milk
margarett must be in there somewhere
she's hard to spot in a bathing cap
here's our heroin in full uniform please note the
bloomer also very immense
abilities follow me girls
light-footed along the highway comes
tireless today no competition some gas
for these to worry about either oh they
were invented all right but there weren't
many of them around in 1918 or maybe
it was just too early in the morning
some things never change hungry again go
laughs a real adventure
so that's what those hats were for
then on the far shore and on our Shore and they
and here Oh problem footed huntsville station
but our girls count is equal to
it I hope the stationmaster is
I am just a Girl Scout modest words for such
heroic exploits but with something in her smile
when she said that did you see her something
so earnest yes she was a woman obsessed in
the yard heroin with her Moore's cold and her
calloused Fanny at Sarah and its doer a blazer
of new trail an explorer in Shore a scow and it
was her special destiny the forge a hand of her
timid or sisters into that splendid new world
that was just beyond the horizon where there
was no end of what a real woman could do or be
she was just a girl but to be your Girl Scout
was really something but wait there's more to
come we haven't seen the last of Margo yes my
final long shot in 1918 you will remember
this country was at war did the Girl Scouts
rise to the occasion yes indeed today's new
role Bambi to sell war bonds yeah and again
yes did they think up newer and more ingenious
ways of helping their country well let's see
there's the goldenrod patron and there's
Margaret she's a patrol leader now
helping out my home son sounds like
an intriguing idea follow me girls
well it looks as if this
family really does need him
look at that garden and don't forget junior
up there on the poor another carpet
up in mrs. Williams oldest daughter
they caught my dear that's
the girl scouts are here for
well it's plain to see mr. Williams was
never a Girl Scout look at those dirty dishes
this was in the days of the cold Doby recall
when lighting a fire was a real challenge
they learn to square those corners
of a Central Valley camp remember
Corre Dora they still a seditious
now here's a nice little man but he does
look a little grimy around the edges
now let's see this all took place in 1980 that
means this baby must be pushing in the middle
years today I wonder if he remembers the days
when he was a bathing beauty with the girls girl
ah women what do they want from a guy
anyway what's so great about being clean
and what a difference even our inner esteem
considerably more cheerful looks like another
recruit for the goldenrod mother one of
the country's first wartime Working Girl
you can see that mother is
impressed and look who's here
goodbye little general and with that is farewell
Margaret and the goldenrod patrol fades back into
time and are gone but not really what these
girls started in 1912 millions of girls are
carrying through literally millions blossomed
out from the golden rods and those first either
dreamers in their khaki hats and bloomers oh the
uniform has changed some and the times of change
and the challenges they have to face of change
some too but the vision that started it all the
thing that puts that look in their eyes that
has never changed a bit today there are Girl
Scouts all over the world going everywhere doing
everything pushing back the edges of the earth
they're flying and sailing digging under the earth
and counting the stars where will they go next
will they try what impassable things will they
accomplish I don't know mrs. Lowe maybe you do